I'll mix logic genomic data analysis
this online program will focus on
analysis and interpretation of genomic
data and is built for students
biologists and clinicians that want to
gain theoretical and practical knowledge
in this field we'll cover the basics of
DNA code variation and genotype
phenotype relationships and use the
hands-on sessions to review several
examples and analyze genomics datasets
our team of expert bioinformaticians
geneticists and biomedical
informaticians will help you gain
practical experience and identify a
project you can plan prepare and execute
on your own we will start by sharing
with you some of the resources that we
prepared to help make this learning
experience meaningful for beginners and
experts alike then we will start from
the basics of DNA how is this data
generated and what information doesn't
actually contain we will rely on our
cutting-edge T bio info platform that
can help streamline your analysis and
analyze large datasets quickly as we
dive deeper into the analysis techniques
we will explore the types of data that
you can use to analyze DNA variation and
understand the single nucleotide and
multi nucleotide variants that emerge
when the next-generation sequencing data
is aligned against a reference genome in
particular we will focus on snips indels
and other types of genomic variation
typically leading to a change in
phenotype when we process the data a
major challenge in genomic data analysis
arises there are just too many variants
to consider that's why we will explore
the role of filtering coverage
distribution of variants and help
identify only the significant variants
that we should consider in our
downstream analysis once we have a
reasonable number of variants to
consider we will talk about how to
perform annotation how to interpret
these annotated variants in this genomic
data we will use lots of reference
databases and statistical associations
that can help explain how the variants
lead to variation we
observe externally for example ones that
cause disease help and disease
progression or cause genetic variation
we will also explore how machine
learning can help analyze these large
and complex datasets once we structure
the data we will talk about several
methods that are commonly used and
explored the utility of these methods in
classification for mutational profiling
signature construction and biomarkers in
these sessions we will cover the most
common types of methods like clustering
regression classification and
discriminant analysis finally we will
work together with you to explore
several examples in cancer drug
resistance and genome-wide Association
studies to develop a sense of a
bioinformatics project how to plan
prepare and execute the analysis from
beginning to end in cancer we will talk
about somatic mutations and association
with cancer subtypes using geographical
distribution of tuberculosis samples we
will explore the way multi-drug
resistance emerges and can be identified
and even predicted other projects will
be included and we will help you work
independently or in teams to find
analyze and visualize data from the
public domain this program will not be
limited to the sessions online only we
will record each session and provide
access to our top quality materials that
you can learn from online on your own
time these are found on the edu T - bio
info platform finally we will provide
facilitating infrastructure so that you
can perform your analysis quickly and
get the results you need as a result of
completing these courses you will be
able to showcase your expertise with a
certificate offered jointly with the
tower bioinformatics Research Center and
the bio clues organization we are
excited about this program and hope that
you can join us